welcome to the internet have a look
around we're gonna watch today from
corridor crew and they ask that you
kindly leave a like on this video their
requests specifically vfx artists react
to spider-man no way home batting great
cgi you knew this was coming pete isn't
that right isn't that right copy don't
give up
bam flack pow anyway guys i only got
this cat to put in videos
to make me look more sensitive and i
hope it's working
you're such a sweet guy
i know
i give once a year to charity
that's all it takes when right off tax
season comes to oh my god i'm paying so
much i need to lower these don't worry
when you die just build a public
structure and then they'll name it after
you and your whole reputation will be
saved that's what i'm talking about i
already got the statue in the bathroom
[Music]
you're not peter parker how do you de-h
somebody's face what's the technique
that goes into it that's just all
against blue screen and it's so
effective the lightning flashes going on
is actually hitting him there that
couldn't have been in the original movie
yeah
pitching the brick that was like
originally not a brick wait really
i would say that that secret did not
leak
i mean except for that shot
this shot
oh yeah you got some splatter to do hey
everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
we are joined today by kelly port an
amazing we met him we met him at the
premiere
he talked to us about effects started 29
years ago with digital domain strange
days was my first film worked on apollo
13
titanic and most recently been on a
disney marvel kick with beauty and the
beast maleficent avengers infinity war
avengers end game and then most recently
spiderman no way helm is the production
side
such a nobody likes big films
[Laughter]
on my last three films if you look at
gross worldwide box office their numbers
one two and three
are my last three films which is pretty
crazy that's gonna feel wow
she's asleep and i don't get any of that
box office
you probably don't get what you're worth
you seem so sad there it's absolutely
true probably for like all of that work
that makes this movie spectacular and
world-reaching as it is they probably
just made like a base rate these movies
depend so much on visual effects and yet
you get no stake in the points that's
kind of crazy to think about was just
for a movie like this they should change
that and you know they will they will
definitely and they'll pay the artists
what they're worth
dude i remember seeing this shot where
they're both flying through the city and
it's like okay zendaya's face is
obviously real there but nothing else i
imagine is real at all what's so fun
about that they used something similar
in far from home this technique that was
just crazy simple john watts i think
came up with it but it was just this fun
sort of doggy cam style where they're
kind of on bungee wires and getting
pulled by stunt guys you know left and
right and
tugged this way left and right and he'd
try to use his arms as he's webbing and
then they would try to kind of do that
in sync and then they had a giant you
know fan blowing on her and then her
face is just so perfect like she looks
terrified yeah
and really it's a great shot
and it's so effective and it's so simple
too some of the challenge comes in is
putting that virtual camera through that
virtual city because all that stuff
behind them you know
restrictions on shooting drones within
the city wow
interesting is like trying to find those
angles trying to find the arc of the
swing make it match you guys would
animate a swing and find that arc and
then put that virtual camera behind that
something i'm noticing about the
sequence here is the lighting so if
you're swinging through a city like this
the direction of the sun is going to
change relative to the angle of this
chest mounted camera but also i'm
noticing shadows quickly flying over her
head there so was that done on set with
like flags blocking the light just
really quickly and you're having to
match that or is that a digital shadow
it's a little bit of both but it's
primarily in camera so what you want to
do is have a consistent sun angle and
then just block it you know okay get
that sort of tempo we would do camera
tests about like how frequent we thought
that would be and this just felt right
so if it was too rapid it would look
weird if it wasn't rapid enough it would
look weird so it's like finding that
goldilocks uh
sort of rhythm i do see one thing here
which is like a nightmare for me which
is motion blurred curly hair that's
crazy
so how the heck did you do that
how did you keep your hair like make it
look so clean it's like all over the
place it's moving it's frizzy this one
was a little bit harder because the
camera was so active and it's one of
those experiences where you saw a little
bit of the back wall you saw a little
bit of things like blocking the lights
and then you saw some painted very dirty
blue floor that people have been walking
on so oh what a nightmare when you have
those kind of things now you're having
to actually create mats from rotoscoping
one of the tricks that i've learned what
you can do is take alternate takes even
sometimes the same take where the camera
is relatively locked off where you can
really pull a nice good key and you can
take just flying hair you stabilize that
and then you track that onto her oh my
goodness so it's her hair
jesus christ from like some other piece
wow i am your hair from the future yeah
that's really clever as someone with the
curly frizzy hair if we ever have to
like do a cut out like for thumbnails or
green screen it is a nightmare all right
so i'm like
seeing that in motion i can only imagine
just how difficult that is i didn't
realize that they like literally had to
virtually build all of new york city
henderson is at your disposal yeah
whereas in the other spider-man movies
the ones before the mcu they would
literally use drone shots and then they
would insert spider-man swinging a lot
of the time that or those like football
style like camera on a wire kind of
things that's impressive man that's
crazy wow and what i did notice too was
that while they do have the shadows and
they're slowing it down one thing that i
become particular about noticing is when
they're past like when they're passing
like the steve rogers building it's so
yellow there probably should be a little
bit of yellow going
yeah so but i'm like
do better next time so you know they
have tom holland in the actual
spider-man suit on set but you end up
replacing the suit to make it unify
everything together later on how much is
okay um good looking suit then it's very
perfect right okay control the eye
movement and stuff yeah muscles you
don't want to see stitching or too bad
or wrinkles yeah so sometimes that's
traditional 2d kinds of cleanup
sometimes it's easier given the
circumstances to just render and light a
cg suit in there to help with that
cleanup process peter you may have
dodged your legal troubles but things
will get much worse
with murdoch here and catching the brick
that was like originally not a brick
wait really yeah wait
it was like a hot dog or something like
that it was a snow globe a snow globe
tom holland grabs the brick away from
daredevil there he's actually grabbing a
snow globe so are those cg fingers on
his hand
you can see it's more of a sphere shape
yeah i guess he doesn't grab like the
sides of the brick with his two
fingers that's like a bad brick spider
finger and same thing with the murdock
there at the beginning like so he grabs
the brick there i didn't notice that
handshake
kind of by the shape of his palm that
he's actually grabbing something more
spherical especially with tom hall in
there with his hands out like in a
sphere shape like this as opposed to
like brick shape i had no idea about
that that's fascinating wait why would
they change that though that's an
excellent question i mean it might be
weird if like a perfect snow globe just
went in and you caught just the actual
sphere of the snow globe yeah and i
guess maybe a brick is a better window
breaking tool like a brick could break
itself and spray all over the place but
i don't know like in a movie you have
control over the fact that you can just
animate it not to do that i feel like
the snow globe in some ways would be a
more meaningful little easter egg brick
feels a little bit more personal and it
feels like new york
more tangible yeah it actually happens
more often absolutely yeah that's like a
hate crime realism it's all about
realism yeah here spider-man crossover
move
hello peter so there's a lot of talk
about de-aging it's been a thing in
visual things yeah 15-20 years i feel
like how do you de-age somebody's face
what's the technique that goes into it
it's a bunch of different techniques
some studios have sort of a deep fake
type of technique it's a lot of
proprietary facial tracking that goes
into it and then they essentially just
track that on and have to re-light it
but it's also kind of pushing tucking
and pulling there's all these sort of
characters
those are things that you just basically
have to now correct for and you can over
correct for it and they start to look
too young or too different and so we
tried to do our best to keep it pretty
subtle but just have it ring more
towards what he looked like in that
previous film it really seems like
de-aging is a catch-all term for like 10
different actual techniques happening
like sometimes it's a straight 3d model
sometimes you're just doing a little bit
of warping to 2d footage sometimes it's
texture work that's like tracked onto
the face sometimes it's ai based stuff
but it seems like really it's a whole
bunch of different techniques all being
applied in different ways to achieve
ideally the same goal and just really
depends on the shot that you're doing
yeah and i don't think there's really
any one technique that's better
necessarily i think it's just different
approaches to solve the same problem
personal preference one thing i admired
about the last fast and furious move was
that they actually used younger actors
for john cena and vin diesel and i'd
like them to do a little bit more of
that i'm not like anti-deep fake or
anti-d aging the route we're going down
though is kind of terrifying for the
amount of things you can get away with
with using likeness or like the wiggle
room like we don't own the actor but we
own the character so we can do this you
know and that's the terrifying part of
where you can where you can go with
these films and not even pay the actors
yeah that and also too just on a
technical level i feel like it puts you
in a real susceptible place to following
to fix it in post syndrome or it's like
we could do anything we want with this
character whether or not we're actually
going to be able to achieve that in a
way that's not going to ultimately be
distracting or call attention like you
said take you out of the movie yeah fix
it in post that seems to be marvel's
philosophy i don't like the snow globe
let's just casually change to a brick
this was so great when toby and andrew
and tom were all there because it was
pretty obviously as you can imagine very
hush hush and it was just such a great
vibe to have them all there definitely
the set was a buzz this is obviously an
incredibly major secret and i would say
that for
i mean except for this shot this shot
got out there uh we made a video about
it but like this was a successfully kept
secret like no one actually knew for a
fact that these two were in it let alone
in it as much as they were what are some
of the problems involved with trying to
keep such an important secret it's just
thousands of people like our visual
effects team is by far the biggest team
there is and often the leaks don't
necessarily come from visual effects in
this case yeah they did or an outsourced
vendor i think okay
where it really came from i think the
main thing that keeps people from doing
it is like they're just going to lose
their job
[Laughter]
forever as a studio when marvel sony
sends over a sequence to a visual
effects studio to begin work we call
that a turnover and then when they get
that it's usually sent as a sequence and
your name is like watermarked across the
whole thing so either the visual effects
producer or the name of the studio
that's sort of the preventative medicine
i guess
you're not peter parker that's what we
gotta look like a [ __ ] trailers
of this movie to drop had like spiderman
going up against the sandman the lizard
electro all in like this climactic shot
and then it ends and it's like oh man
i'm so hyped for the movie but i guess
in was it brazil
that shot in that trailer was extended
another like 15 frames or so like a half
second and it was just enough to show
the lizard there get hit by a ghost yep
obviously we're seeing these shots that
are different from the final thing but
it's not just simply a matter of like oh
we just turned off the spider-man layer
are these shots created specifically for
the trailers yes what all is involved
so we literally just remove them from
the renders and if there's shadows we
have to you know account for those so
they just remove the the andrew and toby
layers so it kind of maybe is a little
bit of just your
just for the marketing purposes rather
than the final product sometimes you
also see it's the same shot like it's a
similar shot from the movie but it's a
different take i'm peter by the way
thumbs are strange
oh you're using your made up names i'm
peter by the way doctor strange oh using
their made up names that happens
sometimes too but yeah sometimes there's
a trailer only shot it's just additional
extra material that's fun to see that
you wouldn't necessarily see in the film
fair point more bs yeah
what's fun
[Laughter]
it was really cool to just to not only
see the three spider-man character
finally come together that was very
cathartic but also to have all of these
villains from the previous movies come
back together but i also noticed that
lizard and sandman here are basically in
their cg versions the whole time but we
only see small little clips of them as
they're real people did they film
anything for this they did not we didn't
really have access to recyphens or
thomas hayden church so we actually
ended up using footage from the previous
films and manipulating it so recyphens
when he's healing we actually used an
outtake and that was shot on film
scanned at high resolution tracked body
tracked everything like yeah wow
especially for thomas hayden church when
he's transforming we had to manipulate
it to get him into the scene
lighting-wise and all sorts of things
like that but you're still using the
footage as kind of like a base texture
because i noticed like he's got sand
porn down his face so obviously you had
to have had like a 3d model of his face
remade and matched in so that you can
have that new particle sim of sand
falling down yeah the lightning flashes
going on is actually hitting him there
that couldn't have been in the original
movie yeah and we have the 3d model of
him and like you said we had to have
that for the sand simulation anyway so
you can also use that as a way to
manipulate the lighting as well so that
chart there is that a full 3d model or
is that footage of him that you guys are
kind of manipulating from someone into
both yeah okay wow i thought they
brought him that bought them back the
first time i watched it yeah did you i
couldn't tell but that was probably
where i landed was oh they got a couple
of shots i guess yeah i was like okay
that's probably why they're in cgi
because i could only get them for a
limited time so kudos to that i do wish
that with the amount of like rewriting
and restructuring and they had to have
known they couldn't get them i wish that
for at least sandman made some excuse
for why
he's always in sand form yeah because
that distracted me the whole time yeah
this is the first time i watched it it's
just majorly distracting to me this
isn't how you were before it seemed like
it would hurt your case it seems like it
would make you really easy to track
where's the box peter with no way home
we had an opportunity to see what's
effectively a full cg character we
realized that a different era with vfx
technology so we had sandman back with
spider-man 3. it was a pretty big deal
to have grain simulations and that many
particles on screen at the same time and
then you guys revisited sandman here how
did the technology change between those
two films with almost a decade and a
half not two decades between them
certainly technology has changed in a
big way more effective simulations the
power to compute more it certainly
improved in 10 years dramatically
ultimately in some of these big
simulations they were like 300 million
particles or something like that it's
like
crazy that's a lot but they're big
simulations and chris wagner of image
works would remind me of that all the
time like
but if i had notes it's like okay just
reminding you that
these are very big
simulations but i feel like that's also
very reasonable it's like you have like
this whole sequence took hours if not
days and so many gigabytes or terabytes
to simulate all this stuff and then it's
like well i wanted this one little thing
in this one corner here to be different
but in order to make that change you
have to redo it all yeah that's how
simulations work yeah you use what you
have so in that sense nothing has
changed in 10 years like what really has
changed is the ability to iterate more
but because yes you can iterate more but
you're iterating with more so you're
always pushing that technology to its
breaking point gotcha well it sounds
like a nightmare you're just turning up
the number of particles and it still
takes the same amount of time
that's kind of crazy because remember
all that talk that was happening with no
way home of they were down to the wire
with visual effects close to the release
date like right when the movie was
coming out what he just said there maybe
just reframe that whole thing and be
like how are you not always down to the
wire yeah yeah especially in a movie
where it's like every shot has vfx in it
somewhere and with so many simulations
to run like that's got to be yeah like
the time management alone on these
things has to be insane and also never
on sketchup and what happened with the
pandemic too of how that set everything
back for vfx artists as well so what
that makes me wonder if throw love at
the north will indeed come out on time
oh yeah vfx that's a good call just
reworking those lightning sims that was
fantastic he comes across that way in
real life too yeah he's like you're like
the exact same way you just like talking
to you in real life there is no persona
here unlike us unpretentious in person
i'm like hey how you doing nice to meet
you yeah i guess you know cool and
they're always like hey you're john's
friend but i get everywhere i go that's
right man just living in my shadow
how's it feel
it feels good
allows me to have an opportunity to do
something productive that's right you're
the harry osborn of this channel all
right guys we'll subscribe to quarter
crew subscribe to the rejects let's do a
pic
daniel gallacher it's been a few years
and we have not run out of stuff to say
about you during these monthly shout
outs we have so many things
to say about daniel new things to mine
all the time the hard drive's worth when
it comes to daniel gallagher my gosh the
things that are just coming into my
brain right now firing i can't get them
focused the words don't stop coming they
don't stop coming it's like we haven't
exhausted all we know about you yet
we
just keep
learning
new things to say about you daniel
opening up and blossoming outward for us
revealing new secrets about you
gallagher
daniel is there another way to say your
name
uh
and you know you have a middle name i'm
sure of it you've been here a while
constant development here oh so
thank you
for uh being here daniel and you're a
you're a great cat love you love you
daniel you're you're amazing don't leave
i don't need your life story
[Music]